so the david pakman show subreddit has
really been on fire i think we have
close to 34 000 of our viewers and
listeners subscribed you can find it at
davidpakman.com
reddit and many interesting discussions
uh happening every day a few of which i
spotted this morning that i wanted to
highlight user stone 500 posted my kids
school district in missouri is closed
for the rest of this week
due to staffing and attendance issues i
got a letter from the school system
um essentially there's so many people
sick
that the school had to close and this is
a really important thing i know people
in these situations as well where the
school is open in principle but then so
many people so many teachers are sick
that the school is closed um until they
can find teachers their teachers can
recover from covid even when we have
this discussion of should schools be
closed or not because of the virus
my preference is for schools to be open
i agree with everybody who says it's
better for kids to be in school in
person who would deny that
the question is
by forcing them open
do you really keep them open because if
they're open and 15 of the teachers end
up having to uh isolate slash quarantine
because they're either exposed or catch
coveted and then you just don't have
people you don't have staff you don't
have janitors whatever and then you
close anyway
what did we really gain by having a
couple of chaotic days in school and i'm
hearing from tons of parents who are
saying that this exact thing is going on
when people started going back
two weeks ago one week ago
my thought was
there's no way that this is going to
work in any real way either you're just
going to commit to the schools becoming
super spreader
nodes
or you'll be open a few days and if
you're actually testing and have some
kind of protocol you'll then just be
forced to close and it's happening just
about everywhere so interesting that a
lot of parents in the audience are
experiencing that and again i think it's
better for the schools to be open we
want them open it seems like it might
have made sense to do remote maybe two
three weeks we see the omicron wave
already coming down
and we'll have those numbers for you
probably early next week the numbers are
looking better and better it probably
made sense to just do remote for a
couple of weeks doesn't sound completely
crazy or or devastating to the students
and it would have prevented this
insanity that's going on now
a really very important post from sw
frame
who said should the democrats try to get
a la carte network tv
in order to reduce the impact of fox
news
fox news is not ad supported not
completely that's true they charge the
cable networks more than other channels
which means all subscribers indirectly
fund the disinformation spewing out of
fox news maybe democrats should get the
cable networks to switch to a la carte
programs i have been talking about this
for years
a ton of these networks
function are viable channels
through bundling and uh and or through
charging really high fees so when you
pay a hundred bucks for cable you may or
may not know that certain amounts from
that hundred bucks go to specific
channels or groups of channels do you
really think that i'm making this up now
okay but
do you really think that if imagine that
there was a bundle that's like golf one
two and three hgtv one through four and
you know whatever i don't even know if
these channels exist imagine that it's
like okay you got to pay us seven bucks
per subscriber for all seven of those
channels imagine that those were
separated out and instead you could pay
a dollar for each of those channels do
you think that many people are going to
say i want to pay for hgtv one two three
and four of course not of course not and
much the same way
um if fox news had a different deal
uh where people could say i don't want
fox news and then they can save three
four five bucks i don't know what it is
fox news loses a ton of money and that's
exactly why they don't do it that way so
yes a la carte cable programming is
something i've been talking about for a
really long time it it's there with hbo
we know the technology exists
if you don't want hbo you don't pay for
hbo it's very very simple considered a
premium channel
um if it were quite frankly if it were
that way for a lot more channels all of
us would be saving money and a lot of
these channels would go out of business
but yes we that's a very very good idea
lastly
a user
brian crc posted question for trump
rally attendees the trump rally started
up again over the weekend can you name
something new you learned for the rally
and of course the from the rally and of
course the answer is no
uh trump has been doing the same stuff
at the rallies basically since
election day right saying i i won and
information is coming up very soon and
the real insurrection was uh january it
was not january it was november of 2020
and all this different stuff
they are not there to learn anything new
they are there to participate in the
cult of personality
and unless we understand that
it's going to be very difficult to
prevent
uh it from happening again
and it is not about what he says it is
not about learning anything we need to
understand these people really for what
they are which is quite frankly cult
members of a different sort a political
cult um and i think that that would be a
really interesting quest we've seen
people do interviews of trump supporters
at the rallies
it would be great if someone on the way
out stopped people and said what did you
learn today that you didn't know before
that would be a treasure trove of
fascinating interview material i
encourage someone to do it i don't want
to be caught dead near any of those
rallies particularly because it seems
really difficult to leave
there was video from the the rally in
florence arizona over the weekend of
people saying
we were not we're not being allowed to
leave they're saying you need to wait
until the full trump motorcade leaves
and then they were allegedly letting all
the vendors leave and there were people
stuck for hours after the rally imagine
trump's late to every rally
drones on for 90 to 120 minutes
and then you're not even allowed to
leave right away insane la i don't want
to go if someone else wants to go and
ask these people what they've learned i
i totally support it but i have no
interest in being there join the
discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit